we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p here is the egg man weighing in
about our discussion we had yesterday
with Pat and Rachel about whether Trump
could name more or fewer than 13 past US
presidents here's the egg man's feedback
on it Dave there is no way Klump renamed
13 presidents no way I'm taking me under
okay what do you want to bet well I'm
not really a betting man but I i do
think Trumpkin could name 13 president I
don't know that he could name more than
that but I think you could name 13 with
truth is we'll never really know because
we can't really ask him this question
with no knowing you'd be studied or not
maybe Jim Jim Acosta has already been
designated as fake news by Donald Trump
Jim Acosta might as well ask this
question at the next press conference
try to name all of them you can name
every single president in order you
really will have to do that for the
bonus show wow I would be surprised if
that's something you were able to do yes
even there's a lot of years there where
I'm very unclear on what was going on
there's a lot of obscure presidents like
William Henry Harrison they were on the
bonus show today what percentage of US
adults do you think have hearing loss
because of exposure to loud noises I
will reveal that number on the bonus
show the Wikipedia source list has now
banned the Daily Mail as a quote
unreliable source for his website for
the Wikipedia Wikipedia website we will
talk about that and I will talk about a
dog breed that is an anatomical disaster
I'm very much against these designer
breeds that have these sort of inherent
health problems we'll talk about all of
that and more on the bonus show sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership
coupon code i voted 17 and get your
david pakman show coffee at david
pakman.com slash gear now available